>>> DEVELOPING OVERNIGHT, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATENING TO
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE TO
BLOCK THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION FROM OBTAINING A
WIDE RANGE OF DOCUMENTS FROM
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, INCLUDING
SOME THAT RELATE TO MEMBERS OF
TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE.
THE REQUEST SEEKS CALL LOGS,
TELEPHONE RECORDS, SCHEDULES FOR
TRUMP'S CHILDREN, FORMER FIRST
LADY MELANIA TRUMP AS WELL AS
SEVERAL OTHERS CLOSE TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
JOINING US NOW IS MARY TRUMP,
NIECE OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
AND AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "THE
RECKONING OUR NATION'S TRAUMA."
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I WONDER WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S PROMISE TO
INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
NOT FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT, BUT
WITH YOUR PSYCHOLOGICAL
BACKGROUND HERE, IF HE'S SO
PROUD OF HIS BEHAVIOR IN THE
DAYS SURROUNDING JANUARY 6, WHY
DOES HE WANT TO HIDE IT?
>> IT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION.
HE IS DESPERATE FOR THE TRUTH TO
REMAIN HIDDEN HERE.
HE ALSO KNOWS THAT HE NO LONGER
HAS THE POWERS AND PROTECTIONS
OF THE OVAL OFFICE TO ALLOW HIM
TO SKATE BY THIS.
I WAS ACTUALLY QUITE PLEASED AT
THE DEPTH AND BREADTH OF THE
REQUEST BEING MADE BY THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE IT SHOWS THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THE SERIOUSNESS
OF WHAT WE FACED AND WHAT WE
CONTINUE TO FACE.
AND DONALD WILL DO EVERYTHING IN
HIS POWER TO STONEWALL, TO
AVOID, TO EVADE AND TO DENY THEM
THE INFORMATION THEY WANT.
AND HE WILL GIVE EVERYBODY ELSE
THE SAME MARCHING ORDERS.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
THE REQUESTS, THE NATURE OF THEM
ARE IN YOUR WHEEL HOUSE.
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR DOCUMENTS
PERTAINING TO THE MENTAL
STABILITY OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OR HIS FITNESS FOR
OFFICE IN THE DAYS BETWEEN THE
INSURRECTION AND THE
INAUGURATION.
FROM WHERE YOU WOULD SIT, HOW
WOULD YOU ASSESS HIS STATE OF
MIND THEN?
>> DURING THAT 79 DAYS OR 75
DAYS BETWEEN THE ELECTION BEING
CALLED FOR BIDEN AND HIS
INAUGURATION, I THINK DONALD WAS
PROBABLY IN A MORE DESPERATE
STATE THAN HE'S EVER BEEN IN HIS
LIFE.
FIRST OF ALL, HE JUST SUFFERED A
HUMILIATING DEFEAT, WHICH IN HIS
WORLD VIEW IS UNTHINKABLE.
SO THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY FREAKING
HIM OUT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, HE WAS STILL
TRYING, ONE, TO SPREAD THE BIG
LIE, WHICH WOULD SOMEHOW ALLOW
HIM TO CLING TO POWER BECAUSE,
AGAIN, WITHOUT IT HE IS SUBJECT
TO ALL SORTS OF CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND LAWSUITS.
SO I THINK WE SAW OVER THAT TIME
A WITHDRAWAL.
HE APPARENTLY FORGOT THAT COVID
EVEN EXISTED DURING THAT PERIOD
OF TIME.
AND WE SAW INCREASINGLY
DESPERATE ATTEMPTS TO SPIN AND
TO GET OUT OF HAVING TO FACE THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS ACTIONS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE RESULTS
OF THAT WAS THE INSURRECTION OF
JANUARY 6, WHICH HE INCITED.
>> SO, YOUR NEW BOOK TALKS ABOUT
WHAT YOU CALL OUR NATION'S
TRAUMA AND FINDING A WAY TO
HEAL.
AND YOU DO THINK THAT YOUR UNCLE
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME OF THIS
TRAUMA DIVIDING THIS NATION.
I WONDER WHAT YOU SAY TO THOSE
WHO SAY, LOOK, WE NEED TO TURN
THE PAGE.
STOP TALKING ABOUT HIM.
LOOK FORWARD, NOT BACKWARD.
WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER TO THAT?
>> MY ANSWER IS WE CAN'T,
UNFORTUNATELY.
HE'S BEING -- HE REMAINS
RELEVANT BECAUSE THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAVE CHOSEN TO ALLOW HIM
TO REMAIN RELEVANT.
THEY CONTINUE TO EMPOWER HIM.
THEY CONTINUE TO SEEK HIS
ENDORSEMENTS AND HIS PERMISSION.
AND HE CONTINUES TO CONTROL THE
BASE.
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY
IS THAT ONE OF THE REASONS WE'RE
IN THE MESS WE'RE IN IS BECAUSE
HISTORICALLY AS A COUNTRY, WE
HAVE NEVER BEEN ABLE TO HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE, LET ALONE
POWERFUL LEADERS WHO HAVE EITHER
COMMITTED CRIMES OR COMMITTED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BEHAVIORS.
SO THERE IS A DIRECT LINE FROM
THAT TO DONALD.
AND I THINK IT'S TIME WE DON'T
TURN THE PAGE AND WE TAKE A LONG
HARD LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE AND
HOW WE GOT HERE AND WHY WE
CONTINUE TO BE SO VULNERABLE TO
AUTOCRATIC, CRUEL AND
INCOMPETENT LEADERS LIKE DONALD.
>> YOU EVEN ASK REPEATEDLY
RECENTLY IF YOU THINK HE'LL RUN
AGAIN.
A MORE INTERESTING QUESTION I
THOUGHT YOU WERE ASKED IF YOU
THOUGHT HIS KIDS MIGHT SEEK
HIGHER OFFICE.
I WANT TO READ THE RESPONSE THAT
YOU GAVE.
YOU WROTE, MY UNCLE IS SUCH A
BUFFOON, BUT HE DOES HAVE
CHARISMA.
IF YOU MET HIM FOR THE FIRST TEN
SECONDS YOU WOULD SEE IT.
AFTER THAT YOU WOULD REALIZE
HE'S A TOTAL PSYCHOPATH, BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
HIS CHARISMA.
DON JUNIOR AND IVANKA DON'T HAVE
ANY OF THAT.
THEY DON'T SURVIVE POLITICALLY
WITHOUT HIM.
THEY DON'T SURVIVE IN BUSINESS
NO, I DON'T SEE THAT, THEM
RUNNING.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL ALL END UP IN
JAIL.
>> I'M PULLING MY PUNCHES AGAIN.
>> I WANTED TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEANT BY ALL
THAT.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS DONALD GOT
AS FAR AS HE GOT IS, BESIDES THE
FACT THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
SOMEBODY AROUND TO ENABLE HIM
WHO HAS MORE POWER AND MORE
INTELLIGENCE THAN HE DOES, HE
DOES HAVE CHARISMA.
HE IS CHARISMATIC.
IT'S A CHARISMA THAT DOESN'T
APPEAL TO ME, BUT IT CLEARLY
APPEALS TO TENS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T SEE ANYBODY ELSE AT THE
TOP OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO
HAS THE SAME KIND OF SWAY WITH
OTHER -- WITH THEIR VOTERS.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT MY
COUSINS.
I JUST DON'T SEE HOW -- IT WOULD
BE LIKE LIGHTNING STRIKING FOUR
TIMES IN THE SAME PLACE.
I DON'T SEE IT HAPPENING.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAVE -- FIRST
OF ALL, THEY DON'T HAVE THE
HISTORY.
DONALD HAD A 20, 30, 40-YEAR
CAREER IN THE MEDIA, SO THEY
DON'T HAVE THE REACH.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE CONNECTIONS.
AND, AGAIN, WITHOUT HIM THEY
DON'T HAVE THE POWER EITHER.
SO IF THEY WANT TO TRY, THAT
WOULD BE INTERESTING BECAUSE IT
WOULD TELL US A LOT ABOUT THE
CURRENT STATE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IF THEY WERE ACCEPTED.
>> MARY TRUMP, T